Norwegen ist wirklich ein wahnsinnig
schönes Land und um noch mehr davon
sehen zu können habe ich mich dazu
entschieden das erste Stück meiner
Rückreise mit dem Nachtzug anzutreten
also habe ich für euch den F5 surf toget
Nachtzug von aus zu nach savanger
getestet auf Hälfte der Strecke musste
ich leider aussteigen weil es von der
Stadt Christian Sand für mich wieder
zurück nach Deutschland gegen viel Spaß
mit einem neuen zugtest
[Musik]
hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
Willkommen zu meinem Video ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut ich befinde
mich hier gerade in Oslo Norwegen die
Sonne geht gerade unter und für mich
geht's jetzt zum Bahnhof denn wir fahren
von hier aus heute Nacht mit dem
Nachtzug ich weiß nicht ob ich mich
freuen soll auf der einen Seite freue
ich mich auf der anderen Seite habe ich
auch nicht so Bock aber ich dachte mir
kommt nächster Nachtzug Test muss sein
und deswegen geht's jetzt zum Bahnhof
1,4 km laufen und dann erkläre ich euch
noch mal wo es hingeht und was dann noch
so ansteht let's go
[Musik]
also man muss sagen ich bin jetzt schon
einige Zeit in Norwegen unterwegs ich
war die letzten Tage in Trump so heißt
es übrigens richtig ich habe noch mit
einem Taxifahrer gesprochen checkt auf
jeden Fall das letzte Video ab falls es
noch nicht gemacht habt und jetzt war
ich noch einen Tag in Oslo und dann
reicht's aber auch aber ich kann euch
allen nur ans Herz legen Norwegen ist
wirklich ein richtig schönes Land und
vor allem auch die Städte trumsa hat mir
super gefallen und auch Oslo checkt das
auf jeden Fall mal ab wenn ihr mal Zeit
habt ihr hinzukommen dann fliegt nach
osloh glaub mir ist verarsch teuer aber
lohnt sich und das gute ist immer wenn
ich hier blocke mich kennt eh keiner in
Deutschland ist mir das irgendwie immer
noch unangenehm so rum zu blocken aber
hier geht's und was mir auch noch
aufgefallen ist sorry dass ich die ganze
Zeit vom Thema abschweife aber die Boys
hier haben auf jeden Fall allen richtig
freshenstein da konnte ich mir auf jeden
Fall einiges abgucken können Sommer
also für mich geht es jetzt gleich um
22:25 Uhr fährt der Zug los von Oslo mit
dem Nachtzug ich habe einen Schlafabteil
gebucht mein eigenes Schlafabteil ich
bin mal sehr gespannt ob es denn da
gefällt hat auch umgerechnet nur 130 €
gekostet wir fahren von Oslo nach
Christian Sand ich hoffe ich habe es
richtig ausgesprochen ist ganz im Süden
von Norwegen ich blende euch hier
natürlich mal eine Karte ein und von
dort aus werde ich dann mit dem Boot
nach Deutschland zurückfahren okay nee
Spaß ich fliege nach Hamburg zurück von
da aus ich habe mir überlegt also ich
hätte mit dem Boot fahren können das
hätte irgendwie so 12 Stunden gedauert
glaube ich aber ich habe es gelassen
weil ich muss diese Woche auch noch was
erledigen und ja deswegen fliege ich
aber immerhin fahre ich einen Teil der
Strecke zurück mit dem Zug und ich habe
auch jetzt Bock drauf muss ich sagen und
an dieser Stelle auch beim fettes Danke
Schön dass die letzten Reisevideos alle
so richtig krass abgegangen sind ich
sehe es auch dass die zugte von vor drei
vier Monaten von mir plötzlich auch noch
richtig viele neue Zuschauer generieren
also es freut mich sehr gern Kanal
abonnieren und checkt die ab ja so Leute
hier ist auf jeden Fall jetzt der
Bahnhof Oslos Zentralstation bzw
mich heute so viele Leute an die das an
meiner Kappe weil das ein bisschen was
da drauf steht könnt ihr das mal in die
Kommentare schreiben
Teenager cool leute das ist auf jeden
Fall mein Zug F5 nach da Wanger steht
auf jeden Fall nicht dran das ist ein
Nachtzug ist fährt heute von gleich zwei
dann gehen
[Musik]
ja auf jeden Fall chillig wenn er schon
da ist dann muss ich nämlich nicht mehr
rumstehen wenn er mich heute schon echt
lange auf den Beinen also schön schon
18.000 Schritte drin aber ist noch nicht
da aber hier steht direkt drauf B&C sind
Schlafwagen alles andere sind
irgendwelche anderen Wegen und ich kann
euch auch mal schnell meinen Ticket
zeigen das sieht so aus also steht gar
nicht viel drauf Wagen 11 kompat mit 121
Leute bevor es weitergeht würde ich euch
gerne einen Sponsor des heutigen Videos
vorstellen denn meine Reisevideos sind
auch ziemlich teuer und ich freue mich
natürlich immer über coole Sponsoren
dieses Video wird unterstützt von papchi
Mobile und ja das ist tatsächlich das
erste Mal dass ich ein Handy spielt als
Werbepartner eigentlich bin ich sowas
auch immer ab nur das Ding ist Papi
spiele ich selber schon ziemlich lange
deswegen dachte ich mir ja komm ist auf
jeden Fall ein sehr sehr nices Spiel ihr
könnt euch Papier ganz einfach aus der
App Store oder PlayStore runterladen und
das Konzept ist eigentlich ziemlich
einfach es ist ein Online-Spiel das
heißt ihr schaltet bis zu 100 Leute in
einer Lobby und werde dann mit einem
Flugzeug zu einer Map gebracht könnt
dort abspringen wo ihr wollt mein Tablet
Spot ist übrigens Hospital müsst euch
dann schnellstmöglich verschiedene Items
und eine gute Ausrüstung zusammen
sammeln und so lange wie möglich
überleben ihr könnt hier jetzt auch mal
ein Gameplay von mir sehen und ihr wisst
ja ich bin ziemlich oft unterwegs und
gerade wenn man in Hotels ist am
Flughafen wartet oder sonst was da kommt
ein attraktives und spannendes Handy
Game gerade recht habt ihr Mobile ist
zusätzlich aktuell das beliebteste
Handyspiel weltweit in über 200 Ländern
wird das gespielt ich denke auch das
spricht für sich dass ihr das auf jeden
Fall mal ausprobieren solltet neben dem
klassischen Battle Royale Modus gibt's
auch noch andere Spielmodi wie Team
deathmat und so weiter und so fort und
was auch ziemlich cool ist es gibt nicht
nur eine sondern mehrere verschiedene
die auf jeweils immer neue updatet
werden das heißt es wird nie eintönig
und langweilig also soll ich das Game
aus dem App Store oder PlayStore und wir
machen jetzt weiter mit der Reise viel
Spaß ach so und ja vielleicht begegnen
wir uns mal in Game mein Name habt ihr
eigentlich gesehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bevor wir jetzt hier den Zug steigen
noch ein paar Infos also Norwegen ist ja
wirklich ein echt großes Land und zieht
sich vor allem ziemlich hoch in die
Länge man muss auch sagen ich habe echt
einige richtig krasse Zugstrecken
rausgesucht vor allem auch tagsüber wenn
man die Landschaften sehen kann ich
werde auch auf jeden Fall noch mal nach
Norwegen reisen um weitere Zugstrecken
zu testen eine ist z.B die nordlandbahn
die fährt von Trondheim bis nach
Bordeaux das soll wohl echt eine richtig
coole und abenteuerliche Strecke sein
ansonsten gibt's drei verschiedene
Anbieter von nachzügen und diese
Nachtzüge Verkehr noch nicht komplett
durch Norwegen sondern es gibt lediglich
vier Verbindungen und zwar von Oslo nach
Bergen von osloh nach savanga die habe
ich genommen und von Austria nach
Trondheim sowie von Trondheim nach
Bordeaux ich habe eine Schlafkabine
gebucht hat 130 € gekostet und ich hatte
halt ein Hochbett für mich alleine also
eigentlich können zwei Leute für den
Preis auch dort drin schlafen Abendessen
Frühstück oder sonstiges kann man leider
nicht dazu buchen also da ist man selber
für verantwortlich das ist auf jeden
Fall direkt mein Wagon 11
ich hoffe hier gibt es auch was zu essen
weil ich habe mir jetzt gar nichts mehr
gekauft
Scheiße schießt bestimmt gleich wieder
auf ach so Leute das ist hier übrigens
wie im Hotel hat mir der nette Herr da
hinten hat erzählt muss jetzt erstmal
zur Rezeption und da kriege ich dann
mein Ticket das heißt ich muss später
auch wieder auschecken wie verrückt da
finde ich lustig hey einrücken
so Ticket Hamburg ich hatte sogar einen
Service haben können aber ich habe
gedacht komm Wecker stellen kann ich mir
schon selber mal gucken ob ich überhaupt
ein Auge zu bekommen okay
geschafft boah ich bin auch echt k.o
geil ein Wasser ist inklusive ich muss
auch direkt sagen ich finde das richtig
gut mit dieser Rezeption in
Anführungsstrichen Rezeption also wird
man nicht von schafft man genervt das
war in meinen letzten nachzügen immer so
da wirst du teilweise sogar geweckt wir
überqueren heute auch keine Grenze das
heißt ich werde auch nicht von der
Polizei geweckt das auch ganz gut und
das Bett gefällt mir ich glaube das ist
sogar das bequemste was ich hier in
einem Nachtzug hatte nur noch 3% Akku
ist ein Steckdose ja hier so Leute wir
sind auf jeden Fall scheiße man sieht ja
gar nichts mehr moin außer mich den
Bahnhof haben wir jetzt auf jeden Fall
verlassen ich habe mich mal mehr oder
weniger ausgebreitet und habe aber schon
festgestellt dass es ziemlich hellhörig
ist also ich höre sowohl da bin als auch
da das sind sogar zwei Mädels kleine
roomtour ich habe keine Ahnung lesen oh
was war das keine Ahnung ist das denns
nee brauchen wir nicht Nachtlampe diese
Leiter ist natürlich um nach oben zu
gehen und hier haben wir einen
Waschbecken
und das ist ein sogenannter Kleiderbügel
und damit vielen Dank fürs schauen diese
roomtour das war's Daumen nach oben
bitte für diese
Krankheit ich werde mich etwas länger
als 6 Stunden oder sieben Stunden
Nachtzug aufhalten dann komme ich auf
jeden Fall in Christian Sand am Bahnhof
an und wer von daraus zum Flughafen
Latschen morgens dann im Morgengrauen
wobei das gut ist die Sonne geht schon
extrem früh auf und dann geht's zurück
nach Deutschland aber ich freue mich
jetzt erstmal hier auf dieses Bettchen
weil es ist wirklich sehr bequem auf
jeden Fall das bequemste nach zu Bett
was ich hier hatte und wir werden uns
auf jeden Fall noch mal anschauen was
hier zu essen gibt erstmal Jogginghose
anziehen
[Musik]
oh ja mann das ist echt sehr bequem es
war super wichtig dass ich wenigstens
drei Stunden Schlaf bekomme weil sonst
bin ich morgen im Arsch und morgen wird
noch langer Tag so Leute wir haben jetzt
12 Uhr also Mitternacht ich checke mal
jetzt noch das Restaurant und die Bar ab
wie auch immer man das nennen möchte und
hol mir noch was zu essen und dann
geht's schlafen das haben wir auch zum
ersten Mal glaube ich und zwar
Ohrstöpsel damit man gut schlafen kann
aber ich habe auch immer meine neues
kennst den Kopfhörer dabei weil sonst
kann ich echt nicht aushalten das kann
ich hier nur empfehlen wenn ihr Nachtzug
fahren wollt holt euch neues kennst den
Kopfhörer wichtig
[Musik]
aber ich bin aus Schweden hört sich
sogar fast akzentfrei an
das wäre es sogar mehr brauche ich gar
nicht
okay da gibt es jetzt nicht so
atemberaubende Sachen die schaffen und
spricht einfach Deutsch aber man muss
sagen die Leute lernen auch hier in der
Schule Deutsch also das kann man wählen
zumindest ist so wie wenn wir jetzt bei
uns in Deutschland Französisch lernen
oder Spanisch ich wollte gerade mal
gucken ob es hier WLAN gibt und hier hat
anscheinend irgendjemand welche dieses
Verfahren kennt ihr das was ich habe mal
gesehen das ist das gibt ich dachte mir
wer kauft sowas ja anscheinend in
Norwegen ganz beliebt irgendwas macht
hier unten auch voll komische Geräusche
aber könnte sein dass das die Lüftung
ist ich wollte jetzt meine Zähne dann
kommen diese Dinger rein okay eins zwei
jetzt kommen die noise den Kopfhörer
drüber und jetzt höre ich nichts mehr
außer wenn ich selber Rede das ist
wirklich sehr entspannt ach scheiße ich
höre ja dann auch den Wecker gar nicht
ach doch er ist ja mit den Kopfhörern
verbunden das sollte ich dann hören
hoffe ich zumindest
sonst habe ich ein kleines Problem
was hier übrigens auch gut ist ich muss
das Bett nicht selber beziehen das war
sonst in allen nachzügen so dass man das
selber beziehen muss hier war schon
bezogen und damit
gute Nacht
ja eine kleine Sache die ich noch
ergänzen wollte bei mir war es jetzt
durchgehend dunkel also ich habe
wirklich nicht viel gesehen manchmal so
ein bisschen aber ich blende euch hier
mal ein Video ein also so sieht es aus
wenn es helles wirklich eine richtig
coole Verbindung und schade dass ich das
alles verpasst habe so zu sagen das
volle Video ist auch in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt
so Leute was geht guten Morgen Ich bin
gerade aufgestanden wir haben jetzt mit
einer Nacht 36 ich muss gleich
aussteigen konnte ein bisschen die Augen
zu machen habe so zwei Stunden
vielleicht auch drei Stunden schlafen so
sieht das denn hier aus ich muss aber
sagen war echt bequem ja ab geht's
so Leute angekommen in Christian Fan
hier nochmal der Nachtzug im Nebel von
Norwegen ja jetzt muss irgendwie zum
Flughafen kommen diese Stadt hat auch
knapp 300.000 Einwohner aber der Bahnhof
ist halt übes Mini das hätte ich jetzt
gar nicht gedacht
naja egal also ich glaube was zu essen
bekomme ich jetzt noch nicht okay Leute
ich bin mittlerweile wieder zu Hause es
wird aber noch Zeit für eine
zugbewertung und die machen wir jetzt
wie immer gibt's fünf verschiedene
Kategorien Komfort Essen Service
naturerlebnisfaktor und Preis
Leistungsverhältnis und am Ende können
wir 25 Sterne vergeben starten wir mit
der ersten Kategorie Komfort hier habe
ich vier von fünf Sterne gegeben ich
muss sagen für Nachtzug wirklich schon
sehr komfortabel war der bequemste
Nachtzug mit dem Michael verkehrt bin
natürlich nur um mich mitzunehmen anders
zum Glück noch nicht ich stehe nämlich
nicht auf Züge etwas super bequem
deswegen gibt's bei mir halt vier von
fünf Sterne Kategorie Zwei essen ja das
Essen ist Angebot war wirklich eher so
bescheiden als ich nach dem Speisewagen
war da gab es wirklich nicht viel Nüsse
ein paar Snacks Getränke das war's
deswegen hier leider nur Sterne Service
habe ich überlegt aber eigentlich muss
ich auch hier zwei von 5 geben man muss
selber sein Ticket abholen was ja gar
nicht schlimm ist aber nee jetzt fällt
mir gerade auf die nette Schaffnerin
hätte mich ja sogar geweckt deswegen
gebe ich dann doch drei von fünf Sternen
naturerlebnisfaktor eigentlich muss ich
55 geben wenn ihr euch das angeschaut
habt tagsüber die Landschaften wirklich
1A ich habe es leider nicht gesehen aber
ich gebe trotzdem 55 weil tagsüber ist
es wirklich geisteskrank das weiß ich
nur wegen super schön und eigentlich
kann man dort allen Zügen was
naturerlebnisfaktor angeht fünf Sterne
geben zu guter Letzt Leistung klar ich
war sechseinhalb Stunden glaube ich im
Zug wir befinden uns in Norwegen eines
der teuersten Männer der Welt deswegen
hier 130 € dafür gebe ich drei von fünf
Sterne der Preis hat mich nur geschockt
für eine eigene Schlafkabine 130 € in
Norwegen fand ich jetzt okay Leute
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen abonniert
sehr sehr gerne den Kanal für weitere zu
Klasse können wir auch immer Ideen
schreiben ich freue mich check das
letzte Video aus Norwegen ab auch
richtig cool geworden und checkt auch
gerne die Handyhüllen ab von Paras haut
rein ciao
und ja vielleicht begegnen wir uns mal
in Game meinen Namen habt ihr eigentlich
gesehen